des boucliers artisanaux pour faire face
aux canons à eau
ce groupe de mères de familles
colombiennes 7 organisé pour résister
aux assauts policiers alors que la
colombie vit depuis la fin du mois
d'avril au rythme des manifestations
contre le gouvernement du président de
droite radicale
ivan bouquet auto-baptisé les mamans en
première ligne ces femmes se parent de
casques et de boucliers en bois qu'elle
confectionne elle-même avec la volonté
de délivrer un message
nous sommes au front pour collaborer
afin que les personnes qui manifestent
puisse le faire puissent continuer dans
les marches parler et lutter pour leurs
droits
[Musique]
nous sommes armés d'amour de force et de
boucliers en bois à l'origine du
mouvement social qui secoue cet état
d'amérique du sud
un projet de réforme fiscale jugée
injuste puis le mouvement s'est
rapidement élargie en un appel général à
la réduction des inégalités
socio-économiques et à l'arrêt de la
répression policière
les pourparlers entre le comité national
de grève et le gouvernement dit van dyck
et ont repris ces derniers jours nous le
comité national de la grève avons réussi
à faire avancer un texte que nous
considérons comme suffisamment
significatifs et que nous avons vraiment
le sentiment de mettre en place les
conditions nécessaires suffisante pour
que nous commencions à mettre fin à
toute cette situation de violence
nous réitérons comme l'a fait le comité
national de grève
la volonté claire d'aller de l'avant et
la volonté claire de mettre en place une
table de négociation prochaine reste à
voir si cette volonté d'aller de l'avant
débouchera sur des propositions qui
satisferont la population depuis le
début des manifestations le nombre de
colombiens qui ont perdu la vie se
comptent par dizaines